das ist ursula potts mark zusammen mit
ihrer langjährigen pflegemutter anita
usinger ursula ist seit ihrer geburt
taub blind und lebt in einer eigenen
verschlossenen welt dennoch verbindet
die beiden etwas wundervolles den
berührenden film über ursula von rolf
ließ sie zeigen wir gleich im anschluss
doch zunächst spreche ich mit einem ganz
besonderen gast thomas moser ist seit
seiner geburt blind seine welt besteht
aus klängen gerüchen und berührungen in
der nächsten halben stunde 1 führt er
uns in seine unsichtbare wirklichkeit
und zeigt warum und sehen denn so oft
die sinnlichkeit und die zeit fehlen
und das obwohl wir doch einen 7 mehr zur
verfügung haben und vieles schneller
erledigen können als blinde herr moser
herzlich willkommen guten morgen vielen
dank für die einladung ja wir haben sie
in erster linie deswegen eingeladen weil
sie blind sind stört es sie wenn ihre
blindheit im vordergrund steht
ich kenne das natürlich dass das im
vordergrund ist dass das ein ganz
wichtiges thema ist gerade für menschen
die die sehen denn die natürlich klingt
das nicht so kennen also von dem her
nein eigentlich stört es mich nicht aber
ich bin nicht nur blind ich bin noch
vieles andere also von dem her ist das
ist auch eine ressource und ich versuche
mir das auch zu zeigen
es schafft begegnungen und ja darum bin
ich hier
genau darüber werden wir gleich und
sprechen sie sind seit ihrer geburt
blind auf grund einer netzhautablösung
können sie sich an einen moment erinnern
wo sie zum ersten mal gemerkt haben
ich bin anders das war natürlich oft in
mannschaftsspielen bei als kind habe ich
natürlich gemerkt dass ich da nicht
dieselben möglichkeiten habe dass ich da
nicht mitmachen kann für mich war schon
als kind einfach das wort das verbale
der verbale ausdruck von sehr großer
bedeutung viel gesprochen
mit leuten geredet analysiert aber da
habe ich dann schon gemerkt oder dass
ich mehr abhängig war dass man mich
irgendwo abholen musste ein neuer traum
haltestelle da waren schon unterschiede
aber ja ich habe das gericht nicht
anders gekonnt wie hat sich das
angefühlt abhänge abhängig zu sein ist
schon nicht immer ganz so einfach muss
ich sagen ist auch heute manchmal na ja
immer wieder eine herausforderung die
ich immer wieder mich über darin die
auch positiv zu sehen weil es ist
entstehen ja auch wirklich viele
begegnungen die jetzt eine sehen die
person sollte er hat vielleicht nicht
hätte so wie ich das immer wieder habe
in meiner sie in eine situation wo ich
über abgeholt werden muss und das
schaffst ganz viel schön ist auch immer
wieder drin
sie haben als kind zunächst die
blindenschule besucht dann das reguläre
gymnasium dann haben sie theologie
studiert haben dann aber abgebrochen und
sich der musik gewidmet haben ein
konzept diplom und lehrer diplom gemacht
gegen gesang und sie arbeiten nebenher
noch als korrektur für die
schweizerische bibliothek für
sehbehinderte
genau das ist mein hauptjob das ist ein
euro job sozusagen
und sie haben sogar eine zeitschrift
mitgebracht diese bibliothek genau die
wir hier sehen wir unsere augen total
faszinierend sein da weiß man sich
verstehen ja und jetzt lesen sie wie
lesen sie in eine seite vielleicht kann
sie immer kurz was wohl das ist das
steht was titelblatt das heißt
sammelsurium das sind so gesammelte
artikel aus verschiedenen zeitungen eine
rundschau in punkten
ausgabe nummer eins februar 2017 und
hier das ist sinn verzierungen sammeln
sammeln sondern das ist einfach auch für
die hände zum berühren
also das ist ein raum ist auch eine
einnahmen genau mit diesen buchstaben
sammelsurium es ist ästhetisch schön für
die hände und hier auch sbs zürich heiß
hier
wie lange braucht man um das lernen zu
können
diese schriftlich ich denke das ist bei
mir schon so lange her ich kann das gar
nicht mehr sagen ich mein ich habe da
mit vier jahren vielleicht schon mit mit
tast übungen begonnen als wenn man das
früh lernt dann geht das bestimmt nicht
länger als für jemanden der die als
aussehen die schriftliche lernt die
schwarze schrift die wie die nennen also
die schriftlich sie brauchen die ihnen
ihr schwarz ist aber wenn man das später
in späteren jahren lehren lernen muss
dann ja ist das schon schwieriger aber
möglich ist es immer es kommt immer
darauf an wofür man es verwendet wofür
man die schrift verwendet und heute
lesen sie ja viele dass auch digital
also sie lesen immer ins e books diese
eröffnung im internet genau und dafür
brauchen sie diese beiden geräte dass
eine kennen wir das ist ein smartphones
kein smartphone und das spricht das kann
sprechen
das kann sprechen das voice over ist ein
bildschirm leseprogramm hast ja können
sie jetzt unterschiedliche apps 8 genau
und ich komme die öffnen wenn ich für
doppel tippen dann wird es geöffnet
schließe ich das wieder und dieses gerät
das ist ein so genanntes ein break des
play und wenn ich hier eine geste mache
stationen dann wird das genauso wie ihr
auch also stationen heißt jetzt hier und
vorher wurde gesprochen
also auch dieser zeile hier rechnet sich
dann diese diese anordnung der
punktgenau oder blinken wenn ich hier
die gesten machen oder wenn ich mit der
zeile kann ich das genauso dasselbe tun
und dann also können sagt da lesen
amstar leser ich genau und dann wird es
dann hier auch gesprochen das ist per
bluetooth verbunden das ist und sie
können so anders schreiben
konsumenten und wir haben ein ganzes
büro mache ich manchmal so unterwegs im
zug und ja wie andere auch
ich nehme an der umgang ist hat einen
bildschirm gesperrt jetzt noch viel
einfacher geworden in den letzten jahren
wahrscheinlich durch die technologischen
fortschritte
also die informationsbeschaffung also
wie wir zu informationen kommen das ist
wirklich viel einfacher und halt genau
im gleichen im selben maße verwirrender
geworden weil hat die die vielfalt so
groß ist also weil es hat auch für uns
jetzt ein riesiges angebot an
informationen gibt und sind darum geht
da herauszufinden was brauche ich was
nützt mir aber ja ich genieße das sehr
mit podcasts und zeitungen und büchern
und es ist genial
sie sind auch mitglied des vereins apfel
schule genau für den umgang mit smarten
technologien genau wie viele dann den
genau genommen und zudem haben sie 1999
die blinde kuh mitgegründet richtigen
raum der stille lang gelähmt licht genau
da interessiert mich das design ein
restaurant
ich denke die meisten kennen es wo alles
dunkel ist und wo sehen die sonne an
lehrende erfahrung machen können wie es
blinkt zu sein
wie war das für sie denn als blinder in
diesem restaurant zu sein und unter
menschen die plötzlich nichts mehr sehen
und abhängig sind von ihnen auch also
das schöne ist ja aus einer ausstellung
ausstellung entstand und dialog im
dunkeln und da haben wir menschen durch
dunkle räume geführt durch eine stadt
also wirklich mit geräuschen gemacht und
durch eine wohnung und am schluss und
ein am schluss war eine bar und da habe
ich gearbeitet und daraus ist dann die
blinde kuh entstanden
und für mich war das halt extrem ein
gefühl der freiheit mich so im dunkeln
zu bewegen zu wissen dass die menschen
um mich herum nicht wissen dass ich
nicht sehe
das hat dann so einfach eine die
bedeutung verloren eigentlich das war
gar nicht mehr wichtig und das hat auch
ein bisschen wie es wichtig gemacht
diese dialog diese freiheit ich konnte
mich bewegen ich konnte den leuten
zuhören ohne dass sie das gemerkt haben
zum teil ist ziemlich frei bewegten
dieser bar und ja daraus ist dann das
restaurant entstanden da ist dann diese
freie bewegung nicht mehr ganz so
einfach möglich weil da ist ja personal
die müssten sich so rumlaufen und
servieren und das ist sehr professionell
gemacht also ich bewundere dass wir das
machen das ist genial aber der dialog in
dem das blind seien keine rolle mehr
spielt eigentlich für mich ich bin
einfach es freut mich niemand auch ich
leben bin weil das sieht man dann
einfach nicht ich möchte mit ihnen
wissen über die begegnungen sprechen
wenn sie auf menschen zugehen der erste
eindruck ist ja eine berührung ein ein
händedruck vielleicht oder die stimme
oder decke hoch was lesen sie aus einem
händedruck
glaube zu spüren in welcher stimmung ein
mensch ist ob die person nervös ist sie
eher in einer stimmung der abweisung der
zurückweisung ist also dass ich das kann
man mit dem haben mit der hand ich finde
ich auch zeigen ob es eben er einladen
ist ob der mensch sich auf mich
einlassen möchte oder eher distanz
signalisieren will darum wenig ist ente
druck ist für mich etwas wichtig ist und
natürlich auch die stimme sagt viel aus
wie wie sich der mensch fühlt ob er bei
sich ist wie man so schön sagt oder so
eingemietet irgendwo oder oder im stress
ist ja da höre ich schon genau zu und
bin ich nach gewohnt so und der geruch
ist er wichtig für sie für mich ist der
wichtig nicht zuletzt darum weil ich
selber sehr gerne dürfte habe ich habe
sehr gerne feine brauche aber ich meine
mit dem geruch da kommt ja auch etwas
das kann man gar nicht so richtig
beschreiben ob man jetzt blind ist oder
nicht das bitte immer genauso gut eine
große rolle wenn man jemanden trifft
also dem im übertragenen sinn irgendwie
das dass das passiert einfach da gefällt
meine existenz schein oder das gefällt
einem nicht gesprochen
was haben sie gesagt aber überdeckt dass
ein paar fur nicht auch den eigengeruch
einer person und das sagt man immer ich
vielleicht kommt es darauf an oder ich
bin das nicht ich habe einfach freude
daran und ich denke eigentlich nicht
also für mich nicht aber es kann sein
dass menschen das andere das so
empfinden ja sie haben im vorgespräch
gesagt dass sie menschen erst kennen und
sich an sie erinnern können wenn sie mit
den zurzeit zehn 15 minuten in team
gesprochen haben
bei uns ist dass er so man lernt
jemanden kennen kennt das gesicht an und
erinnert sich an die person
das ist bei ihnen anders bei ihnen
scheint jede begegnung eine gewisse nähe
zu haben
ich glaube es geht nicht anders es ist
wirklich ich erlebe das manchmal dass
mich menschen die sagen die kennen mich
die habe ich schon gesehen ja musik
musik gemacht im orchester oder so ich
singe und sie im orchester und sie sehen
mich natürlich von weitem und ich bin
den vertraut und ich merke dann nach ja
und ich weiß ich gar nicht mehr so genau
das ist dann ja das ist schon so es ist
eine begegnung die nähe ist für mich
ganz wichtig es geht eigentlich gar
nicht anders also aus einer also aus der
ferne jemanden wahrzunehmen zu
beurteilen das geht eigentlich nicht sie
sind blind weniger oberflächlich so
generell zu das zu bejahen wenn dich
jetzt schwierig aber wir können es
vielleicht anders sagen es sind
vielleicht sind oberflächliche beziehe
oberflächliche beziehungen für blinde
schwieriger wenn man das elektronische
akte weil es fast nicht anders geht also
wir ich meine uns eine schwierigkeit die
wir immer wieder mit denen wir
konfrontiert sind ist unsere mobilität
also die die bewegung von a nach b und
und da werden wir wie wir sind uns
gewohnt und berührungen wir werden
geführt wir müssen vertrauen haben dass
man uns im raum herum führt etwas zeigt
das ist sind alles da kommt man sich
nahe
und da ist dann eine oberflächliche
beziehung wahrscheinlich etwas
schwieriger es blind seien in dieser
hinsicht auch so etwas wie ein geschenk
vielleicht dass man weniger nach außen
sich orientiert sondern mehr bei sich
ist und das ist möglich ich kann das
nicht zur gruppe urteil ich höre das von
meinen freundinnen die sich das
vielleicht vorstellen oder die mich
kennen das die das in der art sagen ich
kann halt nichts anderes
mich ist das einfach so vertraut und
gehört so zu mir und ist in sich gut von
dem her dass wie sie ist wann finden sie
einen menschen attraktiv ein wichtiges
stichwort natürlich ist die stimme dass
die stimme mir gefällt und dass dialog
fähig ist habe ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen abstrakt aber für mich ist es
wirklich wichtig zuzuhören wie wie geht
jemand auf das ein was ich sah gehört
mir jemand wirklich zu ist jemand wach
ist jemand präsent und das sind für mich
sehr attraktive eigenschaften die ein
mensch hat und natürlich gibt es dann
das auch was man gar nicht so
beschreiben kann also man einfach
gefällt oder oder nicht aber der körper
als anziehung die haut zum beispiel
durch berührung ist es einfach
zweitrangig für sie ich sag dann
manchmal der körper eines menschen
gefällt linie darum weil es der körper
dieses menschen ist also weil sie sich
auf diesen einen menschen bezieht weil
die einfach als mensch gefällt mit
seinen eigenschaften und dann gefällt
mir dann auch der körper so wie er ist
weil dieser körper hat für diesen
menschen gehört und darum würde ich
schon sagen dass das für mich in einer
gewissen art zweitrangig ist ja sie sind
auch auf parship partnervermittlung sein
wie ist es für sie ja nicht wenn sich
dann herausstellt für das gegenüber dass
sie blind sind
das ist
immer eine offenbarung oder eine
desillusionierung vielleicht für mein
gegenüber
ich sage das normalerweise erst am
telefon dass ich blind bin weil ich
denke dass sonst mein gegenüber eher
überfordert ist
oder anders gesagt ich kann im dialog
kann ich das besser erläutern und das
ist kommt dann vor dass wir sprechen und
haben ein wunderbares gespräch und alles
gut und sobald ich sage dass ich blind
bin kommt an seine eine schwere ins
gespräch etwas auch so und wie machst du
denn da raus und manchmal sage ich es
ist ein filter nichts positiv sehe denke
ich weiß ich habe eine chance ich meine
die da muss mich ja sowieso nehmen wie
ich bin
also was soll ich dann natürlich und
dann wenn es mir nicht so gut geht dann
denke ich wieder jemand der nicht zurück
schreibt ich habe eine kontaktanzeige
macht und dann höre ich wieder nicht
weil manchmal schreibe ich es auch und
dann kommt dann einfach nichts mehr
aber eigentlich meistens sehe ich es als
positiv weil weil es hat zu mir gehört
und das ist offensichtlich schon für am
anfang das bei mir etwas anders ist wenn
jemand sich einfach darauf einlassen
muss
es ist wirklich sehr anders für uns wenn
wir uns vorstellen wir sehen überhaupt
nichts alles ist dunkel und ich fragen
zum beispiel wie orientiert man sich im
raum und der englische
religionspädagogik schon holen hat in
seinem schönen buch im dunkeln sehen
geschrieben regen hat die eigenart die
umrisse aller dinge hervorzuheben
der regen wird eine farbige decke über
dinge die vorher unsichtbar waren
einfach deswegen weil er die ganze
umgebung zum klingen bringt kennen sie
diese erfahrung ja also genau mit
blättern und bäumen und so dass das kann
eine wunderschöne musik sein zu hören
wie die tropfen auf die verschiedenen
gegenstände fallen
ansonsten finde ich es eher manchmal
auch schwierig mich im regen zu bewegen
weil es kann auch das andere bedeuten
wenn es wirklich stark geregnet und ich
bin unterwegs dann höre ich keine
menschen mehr
die autos sind extrem laut also ich bin
wenn ich wirklich wenn sie nicht wenn
sie in strömen regnet dann fühle ich
mich wirklich blind dann dann gehe ich
und denke einfach ja ich gehe jetzt
einfach im blindflug ich hoffe es
passiert nichts weil ich hör einfach
nichts mehr weil ich orientiere mich
dermaßen mit den ohren und der regen so
schöner ist wenn sonst stille ist zum
beispiel so schwierig kann er sein im
sommer oder zum gewitter ist einfach
alles zu und das ist dann auch ein
bisschen gefährlich also über die straße
kann man je nach dem vergessen ist
einfach zu gefährlich hörst nicht mehr
richtig das ist alles erlaubt
wie erinnern sie sich oder wir haben ja
fotoalben zum beispiel an erinnern und
so an unseren urlaub haben sie auch so
etwas wie ein ton archiv wo sie tönen
speichern
ich habe gewisse aufgaben schon gemacht
das ist jetzt natürlich mit der modernen
technik heute sehr gut möglich aber ich
bin da nicht so wahnsinnig konsequent
wie andere vielleicht aber hat mal in
thailand schöne aufnahmen gemacht um
nachtmarkt und ja eigentlich mache ich
das schon auch gerne und dann kann ich
mich dann wirklich auch in die welt
zurück versetzen wenn ich dann das mit
kopfhörern jahren höre was ich da erlebt
habe ich sie haben einmal gesagt leben
das leben ist klar für sie als musiker
ist das nicht verwunderte anders ist und
was bedeutet ihnen musik die musik
bedeutet leben musik bedeutet verbindung
aufzunehmen mit mit eigenen gefühlen mit
freude mit trauer mit schmerz mit glück
sind glücksmomente auch glücksmomente in
einer gruppe oder zu zweit musik zu
erleben zu zweit musik zu machen sich zu
zweit miteinander zu verbinden
der musik das ist was ist musik und
einfach ein riesiges geschenk finde ich
dass ich nicht nicht nur musik hören
kann das ist schon viel aber dass ich
auch selber musik machen darf das ist
ein ganz ganz tolles geschenk wendig und
sie haben eine neue cd gemacht zusammen
mit einem freund gehen so haben sich
mani matter lieder betont genannt sie
singen nicht sondern sie sitzen am
klavier genau auf einige kleine frau
sehen ich mit aber eigentlich sieht sich
am klavier und improvisieren und der
text und die melodie die gleichen gleich
die lassen wir aber ich versuche mit dem
klavier den text etwas zu erläutern
und das macht riesigen spaß und haben
mit peter zusammen am 26 märz unsere cd
taufe in der hell frei im grossmünster
ja keine lust und da freue ich mich
riesig darauf dass habe ein tolles
projekt haben sie ein lieblingsstück von
mani matter eines was mir gut gefällt
was einfach so die die absurdität
irgendwie auch unsere welt oder oder die
relationen zeigt wo wir drin sind nein
sagen soll mir das finde ich ein ganz
tolles stück und sie sind auch ein
großer liebhaber der stille und da hängt
vielleicht so ein bisschen diese
gesellschaftskritik von diesem stück
zusammen mit unserer zeit bei stille ist
etwas das es heute sehr selten gibt
warum mögen sie die stille so sehr weil
die stille so voll ist mit
mit wunderbaren eindrücken die man nur
mit bekommt wenn es still ist also weil
man weil halt dann die ganzen
hintergrundgeräusche die was einen dazu
bringt nicht mehr richtig hin zu hören
die wenn die wegfallen so wie in einer
stadt wo hat einfach ein hinter
hintergrund sounds quasi da ist und wenn
sie wegfallen das undefinierbare was man
hört wenn du das einfach weg ist dann
empfinde ich dass man viel mehr hört und
hört dann ganz kleine einzelheiten die
dann zusammen spielen das ist dann wie
ein orchester ist etwas eine symphonie
kann da entstehen ja ich finde das
wunderbar aber es gibt leider sehr
selten ich habe das in frankreich mal
erlebt in einem schloss und das war zwar
etwas reines etwas klares einfach
wunderbar das ist ja nicht nicht die
stelle gar nicht
sie malten im vorfeld auch dass sie oder
blinde vielleicht generell ein anderes
verhältnis zur zeit haben dass sie das
leben ein anderes tempo hat eine gewisse
langsamkeit
können sie das erläutern warum blinde
langsamer leben
also es ist natürlich so dass wir für
gewisse dinge auch zum teil uns
zubewegen einfach ein bisschen mehr zeit
brauchen
und ja ich erlebt in meiner umgebung
oder gesellschaft manchmal so dass das
für sehende menschen schwierig
auszuhalten ist wenn wir zum beispiel
irgendeine tür wegen etwas suchen und
wir brauchen etwas mehr zeit und wir
finden es genauso was wir kommen genauso
zum ziel
es braucht einfach ein bisschen mehr
zeit und ich glaube das auszuhalten und
auch zur wieder zu füllen das gehört ja
auch ich mir zum leben das finde ich
eine 1
qualität eine lebensqualität natürlich
kann es dann auch schwieriger sein wenn
ich irgendetwas nicht findet dann
brauche ich hilfe und dann frage ich
dann auch aber ja ich glaube schon dass
das tempo das so zu sagen wir uns wir
machen uns jedoch selber uns diesen
stress das wird uns vorgegeben oder wir
geben ist uns selber vor
das tempo das ja das könnte man schon
wie ein bisschen runter nehmen das ist
dir das schnell wendig müssen wir das
wieder lernen zu warten
ja ich finde ich sie doch für mich zwei
eigentlich also warten ich bin ich sehr
gewohnt zu warten wenn ich irgendwo
abgeholt werde einerseits kann ich dann
meinen gedanken nachgehen ich erlebe
dann aber auch das sehende die kommen
und sagen vielleicht zu mir weil du du
stehst so hier wie bestellt und nicht
abgeholt und dann sage ich manchmal ist
das ein problem für die ich also weil
das wirkt wahrscheinlich eigenartig für
menschen die sehen die immer in bewegung
sind
wenn ich einfach so hier stehe ich bin
einfach und natürlich wenn ich lange
warten muss kann das auch sehr da kann
man sich sehr einsam fühlen ich denke ja
wenn jetzt niemand kommt was was mache
ich dann da muss ich mich irgendwie
selber durch diesen bahnhof oder wo ich
dann bin durchschlagen und naja hofft
dann schon es kommt irgendjemand und
hilft mir dann auch wieder aus dieser
warteten position aus es ist so beides
schön und schwierig manchmal auch sie
haben mir gesagt dass immer weniger
kinder blind geboren werden
das kommt des medizinischen fortschritts
nehme ich an
und dass dadurch etwas verloren geht
nämlich eine kultur des blind seins war
was meinen sie damit und wie könnten wir
sehen denn von dieser kultur profitieren
also ich meine damit das hat für mich
als kind das leben war klang und geruch
und zwar wirklich also es war alles
eigentlich klar auch dinge die wir sehen
der gar nicht nicht wichtig waren war
für mich erfüllt mit klang und gerüchen
und ich denke oder ich fände es schön
wenn sehende davon auch profitieren
würden also wenn wenn da die
sensibilität steigen würde sich da auch
mehr hinzugeben und auszuprobieren und
auch irgendwo nicht zu denken ja wenn
ich etwas mit den augen angeschaut habe
dann dann habe ich es erfasst
ich meine das ist zwar sehr wichtig aber
es ist ein teil davon
und dass man kann
wenn man es wirklich erfassen will als
möglich ist dann muss man es ja auch in
die hände nehmen oder mutter daran
riechen und und das ja das würde ich mir
schon wünschen irgendwie das dach mehr
neugier auch wäre und nicht zu sagen ja
das ist halt für dich wichtig du machst
das als blinder sondern zu sagen ach da
könnte ich ja auch noch viel mehr
erfahren von der welt dass nämlich aus
schlusswort herr moser vielen herzlichen
dank für das offene gespräch sehr gern
geschrieben jetzt gleichzeitig stern
schon eine kunst denn ebenso stillen wie
berührenden film solar leben in anderswo
des schweizer filmemachers wolf ließ dem
sich die sendung reporter heute abend
widmet nächsten sonntag spreche ich mit
der ökonomen und philosophen lisa herzog
über chancengleichheit wo sehen sie ganz
persönlich eine ungleiche
chancenverteilung in unserer
gesellschaft
schicken sie mir ihre meinung per mail
oder gerne auch auf facebook
ich freue mich auf ihre zuschriften und
wünsche ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]